avec nous on a quatre personnes qui ont
des talons il va falloir découvrir qui
fait quoi c'est un espèce de kiki de
confinement voilà je vous le dis cet
indice passe de kaki de confinement on a
ce soir avec nous chante le champion la
championne du monde du cri de la mouette
on a quelqu'un qui lit l'avenir dans le
couscous et qui nous le dira on a
j'arrive à toucher mon nez avec ma
langue et je mets mes jambes derrière la
tête
on a donc quatre personnes qui sont avec
nous ce soir on a violette qui est avec
nous bonsoir violette remercie d'être là
violette alors violette qui un talon
elle nous fera son talent dans un
instant vous allez jouer tous les
chroniqueurs ici violette vous nous
appelez dont vous nous a pedu violette
dunkerque d'accord et il ya également
nadia qui hélas à lui nadia courbe avant
merci d'être là ma nadia alors tu es
aussi bien dont ouais tu as donc tu vas
nous faire dans un instant mais on va
essayer de trouver quel dont tu as
sam hamad à dia tout va bien j'ai
confiance je te kiffe grave c'est mon
jour 2 c'est mon jour de comme on dit
c'est mon plus de joburg de baudelaire à
dire de bonheur et bat canadien je suis
très heureux que ce soit là en tout cas
merci d'être là nadia je te fais un gros
bisou tu restes avec confiance bon bah
on va boire et on va voir tout dans un
instant tondon à julien qui est avec
nous sa luge du salut salut cyril salut
tout le monde
ça va me juger tout va bien ça va il
faut bien tu nous appelles doute à
julien à moi j'appelle bégaye en gironde
d'accord en gironde et wanadoo tu nous
appelles du shérif vernon en normandie
mais on n'est pas loin de paris d'accord
très bien et on à dimitri qui est avec
nous salit dimitri salut salut merci
d'être là dimitri tu nous appelles d'où
mon chéri de harass d'accord alors
attention je vous le dis il y en a
quatre
ils sont quatre et ils ont des talents
je vous le dis pour qui qui à votre avis
est la personne qui est champion aux
championnes du monde du cri de la
mouette castaldi a je pense je pense que
c'est viol est un viol est jean michel
bachelet tabitha de dunkerque qui
appelle mouettes
ouais d'accord mathieu le jeune homme de
arras
prenons donc vous a dit julien oui on
voyait on sent qu'il aime boire pour des
imitations non dimitri gillois dimitri
oui gilles moi je pense que c'est julien
avec sa voix je pense que si julien
d'accord et toi sophie pour le cri de la
mouette je pense que senna bien la
diarrhée alors on a on va démarrer
dimitri est ce que tu peux nous faire le
cri de la mouette pour voir si c'est
bien toi est-ce que dimitri le champion
du monde de cri de la mouette vous
faites un média est ce que tu peux nous
faire danser de la mouette
ça n'est pas le cas c'est pas assez
c'est pas le cri de la mouette sanabia
sas et rabattables c'est parce que tu as
eue et la sécurité de la jebba dimitri
tu peux nous leur faire parce que
dimitri c'est pas mal ces achats
d'accord merci et julien tu peux nous le
faire toi pour voir si c'est toi la
jolie et violette est ce que tu peux
nous faire le cri de la mouette et vas-y
c'est ça continue tu es là alors à votre
avis c'est qui c'est juliette je suis
d'attaqué championne du monde dur et la
boîte est ce que tu peux nous le faire
en vrai maintenant vraiment nous faire
une grosse démo m'a dit quoi et avec ça
tu es champion du monde
biolay tu te fous de ma gueule relais et
châteaux ljubisa m attention maintenant
on va jouer à quilly l'avenir dans le
couscous qui lie l'avenir dans le
couscous ben castaldi je pense que c'est
nadia je pense
il est co sophie koch media aller nadia
mathieu dimitri dimitri et toi j'ai non
c'est julien forcément alors dimitri
julien nadia il reste que vous dimitri
est ce que tu peux nous dire comment tu
lis dans le couscous
je l'avais des pois chiches ouais la
semoule
ouais je le torti avec la merguez
ouais bah ça j'arrive à voir ce qui va
se passer le lendemain dimitri tu vas te
[ __ ] de notre gueule encore combien de
temps doit à jean michel s'te plaît
açores sans allez sortez moi je m'en
sers témoin jean michel julliard vers
moi pour lui avoir le couscous je prends
une merguez
il fait une sorte de pendule d'accord
suite et graines se moulent comme ça
ouais comme sarah et au fur et à mesure
donc les grains de semoule dessine un
mot et ça me prévoit l'avenir arrivez
vous à votre avis qui a le don de lire
l'avenir dans le couscous et toi nadia
comment tu fais pour lire l'avenir dans
le couscous et ben je remue le couscous
ouais et ensuite je fermais par la
personne et elle mange aurel manger un
petit peu et puis voilà alors à votre
avis mais ces explications à ce qui l'a
rendu donc julien le génial agile
ouais j'aurais sur julien je pense que
j'ai gagné julien est ce que tu as une
saucisse actuellement la chez toi mon
nom je peux aller voir mais je crois pas
va voir va voir parce que tu va
peut-être nous faire une démonstration
le jaguar wav asie à battre a dit et
maintenant est ce qu'on va voir dans un
sens on va avoir la démonstration qu'ils
arrivent à toucher son nez avec sa
langue à bâle hors du coup du coup c'est
à dire nadia dimitri nadia sénateurs
prix dimitri aller nadia d'adia fait
nous essayer de le faire
montre nous et arrive à toucher ton et
les calanques non non non julien est ce
que tu y arrives touché le nez avec my
way et julien ici ah mais si j'ai les
arrive à toucher son nez avec sa langue
c'est partout pareil c'est son équipe
face à lens et dimitri est ce que tu
arrives à le faire toi je dirais ou
encore regarde ah ouais non non sinon tu
sers à rien dit et rien cela les six
huîtres il est génial a été chez lui
s'il est vide je vous lis et julien qui
arrivait à toucher son nez avec sa
langue c'est son talent je sais pas si
ça lui sert dans la vie de tous les
jours à part pour attraper de
l'artisanat avec nos talents vous êtes
si vous avez du talent vous allez
débarqua à nous montrer il nous reste
donc je lis l'avenir dans le couscous
donc vous l'avez vu que c'est pas julien
qu'il est l'avenir de couscous c'est ou
dimitri soudas dia et il reste un
dernier truc je mets mes jambes derrière
ma tête
à votre avis qui met ses jambes derrière
la tête nadia ou dimitri maintenant que
c'est dimitri sophie je reste sur nadia
pour le couscous dmitri pour la
souplesse
gilles verdez dimitri l'acrobate
d'accord et matthieu delormeau bakou je
n'ai pas 100 gr dimitri dimitri qui met
alors nadia est ce que tu peux nous
montrer comment tu mets tes jambes
derrière ta tête alors dimitri est ce
que tu arrives à mettre tes jambes
derrière la tête déjà si je peux être
ton avocat si tu veux ou tout à l'heure
avec plaisir franchement tu tu vas
rester la tête
ouais bah si on va voir si toi ouais
voilà et et dimitri ça te sert à quoi
pour la vie de tous les jours j'ai
compris c'est bon il faut soit aurait pu
leur faire le grand gabarit et nadia ma
chérie toi tu ne veux tu lis l'avenir
dans le couscous est ce que c'est vrai
cette histoire où est ce que c'est une
connerie
non c'est vrai alors qu'elle s'habitue à
nommer est ce que tu peux nous faire une
démonstration dans un instant tu vas
lire l'avenir dans un couscous tu devras
l'avenir de gilles verdez tu va nous
dire s'il va re marier bientôt
tu vas dire la cie retient la vie de
julien de violette de sophie cost est ce
qu'elle va aller chez jean michel mr
prochainement voilà tout ça tu vas nous
faire c'est sérieux au ton truc
ces chariots bas alors on va se
retrouver dans un instant médias
explique nous explique aux
téléspectateurs comment tu fais pour
lire dans les grains de couscous comment
ça se passe
moi je commence pas alors on tente on
mal maintenant on attend mal nadia là ça
va c'est vrai ça va mieux
vas-y ouais on en fait moi je mélange
une fois mais là comme on a à distance
on va le faire ensemble c'est à dire que
les crous avec pierre on à castaldi et
gilbert des secousses coup je crois à
bay hill a past abrutis alors gilles
être que tu l'as tu jettes n'en est pas
là malheureusement de jean michel lalle
on va faire on va faire du jus en vie
voilà comme à wisches asie où n'importe
quoi merci les chéris alors j'ai remis
mes chéris merci
allez mes chéris vas-y mon job à belleu
et toulouse je l'avais jamais fait quoi
que ce soit cuit mais du couscous oxatis
a fait ça fait deux ans qu'il n'a pas
lui qui d'akela pape qui n'a pas fait de
cuir un truc s'être mag la bombe à nadia
tu sais quoi on va préparer du couscous
à 80 da ba voila la bad la [ __ ] est prêt
à y avait alain bazille bah oui bah il
fallait le sortir avant l'asie alors pas
du tout il n'y a pas de légumes y à rien
et que du coup je n'ai pas dansé du
couscous un bac es tu crois et je crois
qu'ils travaillent dur et aux est
celui-là a lieu tous les trois que
travaille chez bébert le hive asie j'ai
tout essayé ou souillent non non et non
je suis mangé une cuillère normalement
va te casser une jambe
bah bah tu peux pas demander à ta maman
qu'elle nous en livre les médias
nadia sa vérité je pense est une arnaque
on la donne à dire la gare la chérie tu
sais quoi il va faire son couscous il va
taper à rien et je pense que vous allez
le faire en rente haine parce que j'y
crois pas du tout à cette histoire doit
bien avoir ma chérie nous a pas tous des
chocolats en tout cas les autres à tous
des chocolats à violette à dimitri à
julien à nadia et je vais vous avez été
formidables
franchement vous avez été très très
drôle tous je vous fais des gros bisous
et je vous offre tous à tous des
chocolats pour ce lundi de pâques c'est
pour moi ces cadeaux et bons confirmant
les abats je vous fais des gros billets